if you shoot with an AR-15 let's say you
shoot a deer you can't eat it one time
on this program I gave the women of The
View Credit today is not that day Sarah
didn't get a chance to weigh in on the
uh topic of what happened in Maine and
the AR-15s yeah I I would love to see an
assault weapons ban like President
Reagan I don't believe they're a sport
or hunting um uh instrument it's like
shooting fish in a bucket but that's my
but also if you shoot with an AR-15
let's say you shoot a deer you can't eat
it because you basically demon in
addition to that but the Hunt is about
an actual difficult process not
massacring bodies of any kind but my
point is I'd love to see
that